Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
In computer graphics, when we are talking
about portrait relighting, we mean a technique
that is able to look at an image and change
the lighting, and maybe even the materials
or geometry after this image has been taken.
This is a very challenging endeavor.
So can neural networks put a dent into this
problem and give us something new and better?
You bet!
The examples that you see here are done with
this new work that uses a learning-based technique,
and is able to change the lighting for human
portraits, and only requires one input image.
You see, normally, using methods in computer
graphics to relight these images would require
trying to find out what the geometry of the
face, materials, and lighting is from the
image, and then, we can change the lighting
or other parameters, run a light simulation
program, and hope that the estimations are
good enough to make it realistic.
However, if we wish to use neural networks
to learn the concept of portrait relighting,
of course, we need quite a bit of training
data.
Since this is not trivially available, the
paper contains a new dataset with over 25
thousand portrait images that are relit in
5 different ways.
It also proposes a neural network structure
that can learn this relighting operation efficiently.
It is shaped a bit like an hourglass and contains
an encoder and decoder parts.
The encoder part takes an image as an input
and estimates what lighting could have been
used to produce it, while the decoder part
is where we can play around with changing
the lighting, and it will generate the appropriate
image that this kind of lighting would produce.
However, there is more to it.
What you see here are skip connections that
are useful to save insights from different
abstraction levels and transfer them from
the encoder to the decoder network.
So what does this mean exactly?
Intuitively, it is a bit like using the lighting
estimator network to teach the image generator
what it has learned.
So, do we really lose a lot if we skip the
skip connections?
Well, quite a bit, have a look here.
The image on the left shows the result using
all skip connections, while as we traverse
to the right, we see the results omitting
them.
These connections indeed make a profound difference.
Let’s be thankful for the authors of the
paper as putting together such a dataset and
trying to get an understanding as to what
network architectures it would require to
get great results like these takes quite a
bit of work.
However, I’d like to make a note about modeling
subsurface light transport.
This is a piece of footage from our earlier
paper that we wrote as a collaboration with
the Activision Blizzard company, and you can
see here that including this indeed makes
a profound difference in the looks of a human
face.
I cannot wait to see some followup papers
that take more advanced effects like this
into consideration for relighting as well.
If you wish to find out more about this work,
make sure to click the link in the video description.
This episode has been supported by Weights
& Biases.
Here you see a write-up of theirs where they
explain how to visualize the gradients running
through your models, and illustrate it through
the example of predicting protein structure.
They also have a live example that you can
try!
Weights & Biases provides tools to track your
experiments in your deep learning projects.
It can save you a ton of time and money in
these projects and is being used by OpenAI,
Toyota Research, Stanford and Berkeley.
Make sure to visit them through wandb.com/papers
or just click the link in the video description
and you can get a free demo today.
Our thanks to Weights & Biases for helping
us make better videos for you.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!